pas de bousculade pour prendre son
ticket forcément ça change marie-claire
l'ancienne suppléante d'arnaud
montebourg mais elle garde le sourire
c'est les amis fidèles c'est la famille
donc c'est très bien
des fidèles qui ne se verrait pas
manquer et me fête de la rose pour
essayer de voir si pas moyen de faire
bouger un peu des choses que ya beaucoup
de bousculades tout autour des partis et
on avait envie d'écouter cécile et de
renforcer nos étés cécile untermaier la
députée de la circonscription avait
invité le maire de bourg en bresse
jean-françois de ba et laurent
grandguillaume ancien député
côte-d'oriens à l'initiative des
territoires zéro chômeur le premier est
là l'autre pas il est souffrant
une déconvenue de plus pour l'élu
bressane qui ne désarme pas il faut être
positif de toute façon on sait bien que
nous sommes dans le creux de la vague
mais
on nous le rappelle constamment mais on
constate quand même que au fil des
années eh bien on progresse petit à
petit et je crois que il faut il faut
expliquer dans la proximité ce que nous
sommes capables de faire au service des
citoyens et à quelques mois des
municipales il y a urgence à remobiliser
sur le terrain à frangy et ailleurs là
il ya une pente d'entousiasme c'était le
cas la rochelle ce week-end c'est le cas
ici des gens qui croient qu'ils sont sur
leurs convictions suis comme militant
politique envie de rebondir et il allait
au combat
c'est vrai qu'ici il y a toujours des
militants de la première heure on me
tape que moi je suis pas socialiste en
que moi je viens en curieux pour les
informations contradictoires donc moi je
suis plutôt de droite
je suis communiste donc voilà et je suis
venu plus pour écouter les informations
parce que je suis aussi élu et ce qui se
dit à frangy compte encore apparemment